president Trump issued a stern warning
to anyone planning to stir up trouble at
his rally in Tulsa tomorrow tweeting
today any protesters anarchists
agitators looters or lowlifes who are
going to Oklahoma please understand you
will not be treated like you've been in
New York Seattle or Minneapolis it will
be a much different scene that tweet
came after concerns that violent
demonstrations would blanket the city
originally Tulsa mayor GT Bynum declared
a civil emergency and instituted a 10:00
p.m. curfew around the rally venue but
late this afternoon that was apparently
rescinded so Trump fans could continue
to wait in line either way the next 24
hours and Beyond are going to be rather
eventful my next guest has consulted
with college campuses on how to deal
with anarchist groups that sounds like
fun
he says the mayor is absolutely right to
prepare for potential chaos Chris wacker
is former assistant FBI director joins
me now Chris welcome aboard how are you
good evening kami
well look clearly at this point when you
think about how do you handle a group
like an Tifa or anarchists what should
the city and campaign be planning for
well they should plan for the worst and
what the public needs to understand and
those that are coming to Tulsa need to
understand as the inner federal
perimeter is controlled by the Secret
Service and they don't and they mean
business they're gonna plan for the
worst they're gonna have you know
moderate level of police force showing
but there's going to be a lot of
resources out of sight and in the
background and they're they're trained
to deal with this type of thing yeah
this clearly is where law enforcement
matters they they're trained they know
generally what to expect it's going to
be interesting of course Americans have
seen cities that have not taken control
of the environment isn't I think this is
valuable and I would guess you might
agree that regardless of your position
on the the President or the rally
the fact is it's important for Americans
to see that government in this country
city governments state governments the
federal government can take control of
an environment and that's what they're
going to see aren't they I think
absolutely I mean Oklahoma is a
there's a kind of state that that
embraces conservative values and lot in
the rule of law and what you're going to
see converging on Tulsa is every manner
of anarchists any anybody who's anti
Trump is going to show up you're going
to have elements that are there to do
nothing but provoke the police they're
trained to do it I've seen them do it
yeah they would spit on them they will
throw rocks at the crowd and just commit
all kinds of violence to get away and
you've seen this Chris New York Times
Nicholas Kristof though thinks we're
being too alarmist about MTA he writes
these and Tifa panics are where racism
and hysteria intersect in a nation that
is more guns than people they arise when
a lying president takes every
opportunity not to heal our nation's
divisions but to stoke them when people
live in a news ecosystem that provides
no reality check but in flames
prejudices and feeds fear do you believe
that do you buy into that not a bit I've
seen them in action and people who have
seen them in action and and understand
their doctor and their doctrine is that
violence can be committed against people
they deemed to be fascists their
definition of fascist is anyone who's on
the right of the political spectrum so
if they find somebody wearing a maggot
they will thump him or her they will hit
them with sticks they will they will
commit violence at the drop of a hat
that's what they're there for
yeah well fortunately of course we're
looking at a dynamic where at least the
federal government understands that's
why that perimeter you described is key
and we aren't used to that but we've
seen with Donald Trump rallies before
the seriousness of this when it comes to
the security is there again a at least
certainly a linkage do you find that
local police do they mind the federal
government being there do they mind
having to deal with the Secret Service
or these days is there more of a brother
and a sisterhood coming together in
dealing with keeping people safe yeah I
think the police are very happy that
they're there they're it's not some
mayor's decision it's not not some
governor's decision inside that federal
perimeter it is it is under the control
of the Secret Service and that these
cops will be backed up there'll be
there'll be full support behind them and
they'll be plenty of
sources behind him as well excellent
excellent well Chris thank you you know
this is a time when people are
complaining politically in many
instances about the nature of law
enforcement but when it comes right down
to it our live social cohesion exists
because of that it's a thin blue line
but it's also kind of an anonymous line
when it comes to the kind of work that
goes into making of all kinds of events
rallies football games other other 4th
of July coming up and the importance of
that Chris thanks for joining me tonight
I appreciate it
Thank You Tammy all righty